so the pennsylvania secretary of state
buchvar right who've mentioned
several times here she is very partisan
she had tweeted a lot about how bad
trump is she's a democrat
but she says listen i took an oath of
office so i'm not cheating the system
we have the same sort of uh of
statements from the pennsylvania ag josh
shapiro says all the votes are going to
be counted and remember that time i
tweeted last week about how when all the
votes are counted biden's going to win
just ignore that it turns out that when
you have partisan officials in charge of
elections people tend to get pretty
suspicious
here was buchvar yesterday look these
were four years ago
and at the time i was not in the
administration i was not in
any public service i was a private
citizen it was a personal
twitter account um and you know
i so so that and then when i
became secretary of state i took an oath
dennis and i took an oath
to defend and and protect the
constitution of the commonwealth of
pennsylvania and the constitution the
united states
and partisan politics have no place
in the pennsylvania department of state
or any county elections office
okay so you know again is there a reason
for people to be suspicious
sure is there is there a reason to
declare the entire election illegitimate
yet
no should we see all the evidence come
out absolutely
and should everybody just take a chill
pill and wait for a second while we do
all these investigations and while the
legal process moves forward
yes okay meanwhile in nevada similar
accusations being made the nevada gop
put out a tweet yesterday saying our
lawyers just sent a criminal referral to
a.g barr
regarding at least 3062 instances of
voter fraud we expect that number to
grow substantially
thousands of individuals have been
identified who appear to have violated
the law by casting ballots
after they moved from nevada this is one
of the big problems with mail-in ballots
generally
seriously it's a real problem with
mail-in ballots and it's been a problem
for a long time
right jimmy carter once said that mail
and ballots were right with the
possibility of fraud
i mean this makes perfect sense right i
i just moved from california to florida
shortly before the election and then i
had my mail forwarded to me
right so i looked in my mail and there
they were my california ballots
and my california ballots arrived in
florida now where i an unscrupulous
person i could theoretically
fill out those ballots vote in
california and then also vote in florida
i wouldn't do that because it's illegal
and because it's immoral but
could people do that of course when you
send out a bunch of ballots to people's
addresses assuming they still live there
that does open the possibility of voter
fraud could somebody have
come by my house and picked up the mail
in my mailbox while i wasn't there and
filled those out and i don't live there
anymore and then the ballot gets
sure right i mean the possibilities of
voter fraud are real that does not mean
that the evidence of voter fraud
is necessarily going to materialize in
the numbers that
you would need in order to shift a major
national election
with that said the nevada gop did issue
a letter
to the clark county nevada district
attorney alleging voter fraud by people
who are not legal residents
of clark county the firm of we're at law
group llc
sends a letter to marianne miller who is
in indeed the clark county nevada
district attorney
suggesting that a bunch of illegal
ballots have been accepted
they say this firm in conjunction with
harvey and benally pllc represents
donald trump for president as you know
we've been concerned for months about
improper ballots being cast in the 2020
general election
yet joseph gloria has yet to take any
reasonably basic and fundamental steps
to ensure male ballots are free from
fraud and abuse his inaction is had and
continues to have material adverse
consequences on our election security
we've confirmed thousands of votes have
been cast improperly
indeed we've initially identified over 3
000 voters who moved from nevada before
the election but still cast ballots in
this election
we verified this by cross-referencing
the list of general election voters with
publicly available change of address
records for example
demographic experts agree the national
change of address database only captures
about one-third of relocations
so we think that this number will likely
grow by 6 000 voters at a minimum
okay well that starts to look closer to
the margin of error
in nevada given the current vote counts
okay so again all of this
should be checked into now does that
mean that every allegation of voter
fraud is real
no doesn't mean that every voter
irregularity report is real no
it does mean once again for the one
thousandth time just as i said earlier
this week
you shouldn't declare victory in an
election until all the votes have been
counted
this holds true for every single side
and i am amused at the democrats who say
that this is only true
so long as donald trump is declaring
victory but it is not true if joe biden
or his team are declaring victory if the
democrats declare victory we all go home
happy
if the republicans declare victory
they're very immoral and bad that is the
way the logic of the media and the
democrats work